hi i'm jordan fisher how you guys I'm
Lana Condor and I'm no listen today we
are here today with BuzzFeed playing a
little game called sinkers ever zing and
this is the love triangle edition get
[Music]
first on friends do you ship Rachel with
Ross or Rachel with Joey that's Ross
take this one I like it's facing this
one I'm gonna go with Ross that's it
good yeah it's definitely it's
definitely wrong oh we're clicking it
yeah we're gonna click it it's a quiz
I'm sorry I love having the argument
about Ross and Joey in Twilight do you
ship Bella with Edward or Bella with
Jacob so Jacob Jacob hardcore Jacob
first sure Jacob died myself action well
actually no I can't change my thing
actually I want to go with I'm gonna go
with that word actually why is that well
because because Jacob imprinted with
five minutes to explain the art director
Michael to me and we acted it out what
imprinting yes oh we went there it kind
of sums up this like whatever it is that
you need but could even be an inanimate
object with Michael or Jane with Raphael
I love Jane the Virgin I'm gonna go with
I know everybody figure out that
everyone there's a 0 / 0 % with Michael
I mean come on you know this one I love
just I'm a big fan of the Hunger Games
so do you ship Katniss with Gale or
Katniss with Peeta not everyone in the
Capitol is a bad person I like that
so a capital person let Hannah be a
capital person and let me be somebody
that loves the good I'm going with Gale
I'm going with Peeta aroma Peeta
and section city do you ship carry like
mr. John Corben
yes Oh Johnny daddy okay cups hot is
here throw it up to big compost I don't
want six in the city
oh it's my favorite movie of all time
I've never seen love actually do chef
Juliet with Mark or Juliet with Peter
I've never seen it here we go now they
fell in love the right way he stepped up
he said hey I got feelings for you and
then homeboy mark like develop feelings
over a period of time of his homie
dating Keira Knightley and and then
without trying to wreck a home I should
be has feelings about this it's my
favorite movie
oh okay on scandal do you ship Olivia
with Fitz or Olivia with Jake listen she
looks like she's like their relationship
is toxic though like Olivia and Fitz
have you seen no I haven't pushed up
against a wall they're both power-hungry
so they're obsessed with power
yeah he's like the most powerful man
yeah talk to me about Jake Jake Jake is
a protector man named Jake Gilmore Bruce
do chef Rory with Jess or Rory with
Logan oh is that Milo jess is Milo
I don't just like this picture of them
kissing in Little Women do you ship
Lauri with Jo or Lauri with Amy
that's Florence right yeah freaking
she's every actors favorite actor just
like that honestly this summer bro the
first 20 minutes of this summer you know
I would yo like I can't even bro me
talking about mid samar and some
Florence I was like get out we're just
like and tears that was me you know
what's tripping crazy you realize that
every every time you felt the most
unsettled it was beautiful and daytime
yeah well that yeah
yeah you said the same thing
ah I love this one on the Vampire
Diaries do your ship Elena with Stefan
or Elena with Damon there's one right
answer
she's scared on left side is a fleam but
I promise you would a fine fine no I'm
gonna come dude you have to do it to
your quiz the move in the notebook do
you ship ally with no or Ally come on
and finally in to all the boys PS I
still looked working do you see ship
Laura Jane with Peter or Laura Jean with
John Ambrose I actually ship launching
the Peter and I ship largely with John
[Music]
listen timing
now you gotta answer this sure I know I
know
wait when did you take oh come on I pick
Peter oh gee but also listen you guys
this question keeps me up at night don't
I your disappointment is M&E no no no no
no wait okay take-backsies John Ambrose
no no I'm just saying I'm not surprised
thank you so much for watching we are
finishing up please make sure that you
take the poll quiz on BuzzFeed and watch
12 boys PS I still love you only on
Netflix February 12 sure
by
[Music]